welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down Mission Impossible dead
reckoning your mission if you choose to
accept it is to come with us as we talk
about the film and also its ending part
two is due to release on the 28th of
June 2024 and we actually know a fair
bit about it obviously heavy spoilers
ahead so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out then I highly recommend
that you check out now please hit the
Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the video
and don't forget to subscribe for more
breakdowns like this every day well the
way this video will explode in five
seconds yes somehow
[Music]
thank you
now one thing that the trailers didn't
give away is that the villain in this
movie is actually AI
not only is Ethan going rogue every 25
minutes but the AI is now two and the
sentient Tech is down to become the new
Skynet able to dish out misinformation
it can control the truth and it's
something I could bring an end to
everything we know now I don't really
get the feeling that it wants to destroy
humanity and instead I feel like it
wants to control us in a way that it
becomes a God to us it's been through
every security system social media app
and your grandma's mobile and now has
its presence in everything if you've
ever seen Westworld season 3 then I'm
sure you'll instantly recognize the
similarities and it shares just beyond
the control aspect that was part of the
AI in that rehoban was also capable of
doing complex calculations through the
use of an algorithm and this allowed it
to predict human behavior this is
something entity can do too and it uses
its age in Gabriel to carry out missions
for it couldn't help thinking this was
an odd to the angel of the same name and
with the machine being like a god that
they clearly picked that name for a
reason erasing all footage of him in
real time he's remain mainly ghost in
the system but he actually has ties to
Ethan's past when they were younger
Gabriel murdered one of Ethan's friends
slash girlfriends in front of him and it
gives Ethan a big Vendetta against him
it's basically like yeah like the Fast
and Furious if the Fast and Furious
wasn't as for the AI you might be a
bit confused about how the film starts
due to everyone switching sides
throughout the movie and the exposition
being heavier than the spoilers on this
channel I will try and explain it though
as simply as possible but bear in mind
there is a lot of spinning plates here
well
we're waiting so the movie begins with a
Russian submarine known as the
sevastopol carrying a test on its
experimental stealth technology an enemy
submarine seemingly appears on its
system and the crew fire at it believing
that it shot first however that was a
lie and it turns out that the
entity had just been manipulating the
computer systems on board to make the
subfire on itself later on we meet the
head of National Intelligence played by
Carrie Ells who I still hate because of
Liar Liar anyway he's replaced Angela
Bassett
[Music]
but we do see a photo hanging up in the
office anyway we learned the truth about
what happened on the sub and it turned
out that an early version of The Entity
was injected into it Ramada kagada it
was just meant to sabotage its stealth
capabilities but it went rogue like
Bobby from X-Men and then took it down
you see the AI was originally supposed
to get into the system carry out its
charging horse and then erase all traces
of itself after its mission was over its
sentience stopped it from doing this
though and instead it destroyed
Humanity's chance of getting to it by
blowing up the sub thus it's almost
impossible to find and it's sort of a
mission is the mission's impossible to
get down to it now there are other
and there are other versions out there
on the internet but as long as it's
cause intact it'll never be fully
destroyed those and the submarine had a
key that contained access to the drive
in which it was located and this is
accessed through two Cross Keys that
when combined allow the user to open it
up when the sub was destroyed the bodies
of the crew floated up to the surface
and both keys were retrieved and then
moved on to the black market everyone
wants their hands on them and this is
how they can access the version of The
Entity which still exists in the
computer hard drive whoever gets to this
first can either control or destroy the
entity and the movie centers around
everyone trying to get the keys now this
of course includes Ethan Hunt who's once
more heading up an IMF team alongside
Luther Benji and eventually Elsa after
tracking one half of the kidun airport
he comes across a thief named Grace
who's played by none other than my girl
Hayley Atwell she completely steals the
show and basically becomes like how
Nolan handled Catwoman in his Batman
movies she's got a long rap sheet and is
sort of in over her head working for for
people who don't care if she lives or
dies and that's where Ethan comes in and
together he and the team attempt to
track the keys down leads to some major
major action scenes and lots of back and
forth that happen with Grace I think I'd
also be remiss for not pointing out the
video game influences in the film and
it's clearly ripping on things shown in
both the metal gear and Uncharted series
the movie's openings also akin to the
opening of the spy who loved me and
there's lots of callbacks to earlier
moments in the franchise too Ethan is
constantly doing sleight of hand tricks
with the keys which is semi-annuals who
did throughout the first film on top of
this Max's daughter Alana returns and
kittridge is back the son of a is
back as well the third act yet it's
basically a replay of the third Act of
the first movie with a deal going down
on the train involving him Alana and
Ethan now Ethan's also tracked by agents
of a group known as the community who we
see early ons the heads of several
different US Agencies led by Shea Wiggum
he's desperate to track Ethan down but
like the old cliche we kind of see is
that he's not really the bad guy here
and all this death defying stuff does
come with its downsides though as Elsa
is sadly killed by Gabriel during the
midpoint of the movie I did feel like
this did fall a bit flat though and was
kinda hoping we'd get more anger from
Ethan but he kind of just brushes it to
the side man's got a new girl now but I
think it's a shame as as Elsa was
someone who helped Revitalize the
franchise but Ethan it doesn't really
seem that affected by in my opinion now
he probably could have actually saved
her but unfortunately he was stopped by
Gabriel's right-hand woman Paris played
by Palm Clementi if she ends up swapping
sides and in the end she saves him due
to the character sparing his life now
this is important as it seems like she
may die the end but we know from the
news on part two that that isn't the
case pom welcome back for the next film
and my guess is that she's gonna end up
working alongside Ethan anyway
everything leads to a deal going down on
the Orient Express with all sides
attempting to get their hands on the
keys remorseful adiosa died for her
grace works with the IMF and she goes on
the train disguise the Solana she knocks
her out and goes to the deal with
kitrage whilst Gabriel destroys the
brakes and also kills denlinger he
actually proposed an aligned to himself
and the unity as it would give the US
unlimited power however due to him
knowing what's actually on the console
Gabriel kills him so the info can't get
out now this is eventually given over by
pom to Ethan what in what I think was
Fred you know what I'll be honest with
you my wife was talking through that
that bit asking what was going on I was
sitting there going I'm trying to find
out myself love of trying to find myself
so uh yeah in the end she does tell
Ethan exactly where everything is with
the Sebastopol and that kind of sets up
where things are going to go in that
third film now if you've seen Westworld
season 3 then you know a big twist in
that is that Sorak isn't so much working
with rehoboam I am gonna spoil that to
talk about what things happening with
Gabriel So if you don't want to know
then please skip ahead about 30 seconds
alright so in Westworld season 3 3
though it seems like Sorak is working
alongside the AI That's not really the
case what's actually going on is that he
has an earpiece with a direct link to it
and this somewhat uses him to act as a
puppet with its algorithm and
calculations it instantly works out the
outcome of every single situation and it
then plans ahead a route to navigate
them it then feeds to Sorak exactly what
he should do and say which I think is
something that's happening with Gabriel
too for example he seems to know out
that blue what's gonna happen with Paris
and he also rattles off things to Grace
in the moment he'd only be able to do
this if he had a direct link up to it
and now he's got the watch I think it
goes beyond that now after crash landing
on the train and saving grace Ethan
Saving Grace is that he manages to get
the keys fighting Gabriel on top of the
train he manages to steal the keys back
and it seems like he's gone and saved
the day about the rides not over yet and
Gabriel manages to escape before blowing
the bridge further down the track he
instructs the community agents to
evacuate people further down the train
while seeing Grace will go to the front
to stop it this fails though and the
front end ends up going off the bridge
which leads to what's a brilliant scene
with Ethan and Grace trying to climb out
of it this is when he saved by Paris and
she tells him about the Sebastopol and
Ethan ends up jumping off the train with
a parachute Escape that was planted
there for him now this point Kittredge
arrives and Grace tells him that she
wants to accept a position in the IMF
now we don't learn too much about
Ethan's past but it's made clear that
before joining the team it was a bit of
a rogue you could say we know he was
offered something similar and accepting
this means that they'll always work for
the powers that be but they'll get to
have a life either way Ethan's now out
on the road again and he's gonna be
making his way to the Sebastopol whilst
everyone tries to get there too alright
so what's on the actual Sebastopol
itself I have my own dude two times you
could say this
time impossible so weirdly even after
they reveal what it is we still have a
kind of mystery surrounding it I feel
like it might not be purely as it seems
and instead I think there may be more to
it last night me and the team were
throwing out all kinds of theories after
watching it and we said it might be
stuff like the knock list the cheetah
turned Lara Croft naked on the
PlayStation 1 Tomb Raider Tom Cruise's
anti-aging regime and stuff people would
desperately want now it's the knock list
but this discussion led us to talk more
about Westworld and with it being so
similar that I could see it being the
same thing in the show rehoboam used its
algorithm to control everyone on Earth
and it created Social Security scores
and predictions for how everyone would
live their lives due to it having
in-depth knowledge of how they would act
in certain situations it kept people in
certain jobs stopped others from having
children and basically ran everything to
its exact design another thing the main
focus on the entity is it controlling
the news I think potentially they could
up at a level and have a control
everyone on Earth I think this ties in
the title itself another phrase dead
reckoning has its own meaning it could
go beyond the face value now in Z terms
this is a phrase used to calculate one's
position and they do it by the distance
not being any landmarks around them so
for example if you say if we traveled
three miles from this position going
back to where you were you now know
exactly where you are now this is also
why the submarine Captain says it at the
start
he said it he said it however it also
means an inevitable course which I feel
isn't just applicable for Ethan but it's
also applicable for Humanity if the
entity gets out it could infect every
single system and set a course for every
human on the planet this would mean that
we were complete slaves to it and unable
to advance beyond the path that the
machine had laid out for us might not be
true but I think it's worth bringing up
and in the end it's just a theater
due time you went full on Rogue never go
full on Rogue now as for that Reckoning
Part 2 there's actually some things that
we know are gonna be happening in the
film originally these two movies were
billed as being send-offs to Ethan Hunt
however things have obviously changed
behind the scenes as we now know that's
no longer the case just last month
director Christa Macquarie had an
interview with Fandango where he
clarified that things had indeed changed
instead of just doing these final two
parties said they were developing ideas
for the future installment so it's
likely that this is gonna be the end
there's also the fact that Tom Cruise is
being doing the Press tour for the movie
and inevitably the Indiana Jones films
were brought up as well with Cruz now
being 61 people asked if he thought he'd
still be doing it in his 80s and he said
he'd love to still be playing Ethan 20
years from now more like making it to
the bathroom impossible
now the wga writer's strike could
potentially impact the movie and we now
know that they have stalled filming
however the cast and creative team are
doing the press to us at the moment so
hopefully by the time that's finished
the writers in studios will have come to
an agreement and when discussing how far
into the production process they were
Macquarie said we've shut all but one of
our International locations we've shot
our big action except for the biggest
set piece the central set piece of the
film which is massive and unlike
anything we've done and I think unlike
anything you've seen now we know that at
least one of the cents in the film
features Crews flying a biplane which
ends up upside down when promoting part
one Cruz did a promotional video from
their filming of this moment where we'll
get careful Tom be careful Emmy you hurt
yourself now from other shots we've seen
Ethan's gonna be hanging upside down on
the plane and flying alongside another
both of these are actually from the
World War II era and I think this has
been chosen because there's no computers
in the system makes sense to use all the
vehicles that can't be hacked and yeah
that's why I'm guessing it's here and
also because Tom Cruise is just mental
guy keeps coming up with different ways
to try and kill himself and uh yeah
that's that's another one for you there
Tom now that's what my thoughts in the
movie I kind of went into this a little
trepidatious due to how 2023's been
there's been a lot of movies that have
been hyped up so much and they've let me
down to the point I didn't want to go in
with crazy expectations even with its
high critic score however I'm happy to
say I loved it and this was an
incredible feat that though a little
long still delivered on every level for
me as always the action is top class in
these things but they've mastered it in
every single aspect the car rides fights
and Generals by S been our stuff are all
top drawer leading to this being one of
the best movies of the Year Tom Cruise
continues his incredible run as Ethan
Hunt doing incredible runs and it's
crazy a thing that the guy is 61. at a
time when he should be winding down he's
getting better and better and you can
tell he continues to put his heart and
soul into this stuff that's really what
I respect the guy for and if you watch
him in any interviews or check out his
social media you can definitely tell
that he absolutely loves film guy will
go and see every movie there is and I
can't think of someone who puts the
amount of effort into films that this
guy does seems so grateful that people
look out and watch his films as well and
in a time where we don't have to he
should be uploaded for how much he wants
to make the movies the best that they
can be in the air where you have Indie
John Wick and extraction returning I
feel Tom needs the pack here not once
does this seem phoned in or like they've
just done it on the cheap and everything
about this movie is the best that it
could be watching an IMAX blew me away
and the score scale in general feel of
the film I was absolutely breathtaking
although it's Tom's movie I also think
in The Supporting Cast delivered here as
well I've been a big Hayley Atwell fan
since the first Captain America and I
think that she really shines here too
she can be vulnerable cocky and also the
voice of the audience in what could have
potentially been just a cookie cutter
character I know when there's a strong
female character in the film that
there'll be people who complain it's
woke but to be honest I don't see how he
could find fault and what Haley delivers
here where ding the film is a minor
Parts like the heaviest of exposition
and there are some scenes where they're
delivering information where I think you
know audiences are smart enough to pick
this up on the go as we're going through
the scene so we really didn't need
someone telling us these things before
they happened and removing this would
have probably helped with the runtime I
also think the film kinda gets lost in
itself at points with most of the
characters swapping aside throughout the
point I had no idea who was who and what
team they were on unfortunately I also
felt Elsa's death didn't quite hit home
as much as it could have and it was
slightly lessened by the fake algae he
had at the start of the movie she's one
of my favorite characters in the
franchise and I just wished it had hit
home a bit more still though this was a
master class on how to make an action
movie and in a time when films are
falling flat Tom Cruise makes it clear
why we should still go to the cinema
it's kind of weird because the flashing
across the spider-verse had lots of
similar elements and Nissan Indiana
Jones they also do too they have a
quirky British brunette sidekick two
halves of a MacGuffin that need to be
put together and a big scene on an
old-timey train that leads to a bridge
being blown with a flash I feel like
across the spider-verse sucked all the
wind out of the room and they did it
better before DC had a chance to yeah
though I feel it's the opposite with Tom
out doing that movie in every single way
guy completely killed it and I think
this is gonna be the runaway hit the air
which you know what it also deserves to
be too all my nitpicks to the side had a
really great time with the film and in
the end I'm hyped to see what's next
dead reckoning part 2 it can't come soon
enough but as for this film it scores a
9 out of 10.
[Applause]
obviously let me know your thoughts on
the movie in the comments below did you
enjoy it did it live up to the hype
comment below and let me know please
drop a like on the video as well and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
you also have our merch store over at
shop zeroedition.com which sells lots of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more
who just launched a secret Invasion
slash Pulp Fiction and spy t-shirt so if
you want to head over then help us out
then the links in the description now if
you want something else to watch we've
got a breakdown of Terminator 2 on
screen right now which is lots of fun
and we go very in depth on the movie we
had a bit of an issue with copyright
where Studio Canal blocked it everywhere
except for America so if you click it
and it doesn't load then please just use
a VPN hopefully I'll see you over there
after this and yeah thanks for checking
out the video I've been poor and I'll
see you next time take care peace